wenn du einen gemüsegarten anlegen
möchte ist die aber vielleicht ein
bisschen unsicher bist welche rebfläche
oder welche garten größe denn zu dir und
deinem alltag deinem garten und
vielleicht auch seinem erfahrungsschatz
passen könnte dann bleibt mal dran denn
genau das wollen wir heute herausfinden
eine gute nachricht für all diejenigen
von euch die vielleicht weniger platz
zur verfügung haben ist da ist ein
kleiner garten oft viel viel viel
produktiver ist als ein großer garten
weil man da seine ungeteilte
aufmerksamkeit auf ein kleines stück
land lenkt man merkt sofort wenn
irgendwo eine lücke ist die man füllen
könnte laut den platz oft viel
effektiver aus als in einem großen
garten wo einem schnell mal was durch
die lappen geht aber wenn du dich wird
gemüse komplett oder zumindest den
sommer über selbst versorgen willst also
wenn das sein ziel ist dann muss
natürlich schon ein bisschen mehr fläche
her
ich würde aber gerade wenn du wenig
erfahrungen hast am anfang eher noch ein
bisschen kleiner anfangen natürlich
nicht ganz klein also man kann sich
schon und sich was zuzutrauen
ich kann ja mal erzählen wie wir das
gemacht haben also wir haben im ersten
jahr ungefähr acht quadratmeter begehrt
hat der hätte ich mir auch schon mehr
zugetraut also das war schon relativ
wenig aber wir hatten eben auch schon
große ziele als ich wusste ich will
unser gemüse komplett selber anbauen
aber habt dann eben auch weil wir
überhaupt nicht so viel platz hatten in
dem garten dann eher noch eine kleine
fläche begehrt hat das war aber zum
einsteigen auch super also da habe ich
schon super viel geerntet und auch super
viel gelernt wir haben glaube ich keinen
knoblauch mehr zugekauft und salat auch
komplett aus dem eigenen garten geerntet
also da ist schon eine ganze menge
möglich gerade wenn man sich voll darauf
konzentriert und die beete ganz effektiv
nutzt dazu kommt übrigens demnächst auch
noch ein video wo es um die gestaffelte
aussaat geht also gerne den kanal
abonnieren wenn euch das interessiert im
zweiten jahr waren es dann schon
ungefähr 35 quadratmeter das war schon
ein richtiges fest für mich aber ich
hatte eigentlich ich musste mich schon
bremsen dass ich den garten nicht zu
schnell zu groß werden lassen weil ich
eben enorm viel lust auf hatte und
eigentlich gar nicht genug beta haben
konnte aber das war eine ganz gute größe
und dem dritten jahr sind wir dann auf
200 quadratmeter hoch das ist jetzt die
reine bildfläche also ohne wege
und dann haben wir uns in den letzten
jahren weiter auf ungefähr 300
quadratmetern fläche erhöht wir ernten
da das gemüse für drei personen man kann
aber generell als faustregel sagen dass
man ungefähr 60 quadratmeter pro person
braucht wir bauen jetzt auch noch so
sachen wie hart meist zum backen an
deswegen ist das bei uns ein bisschen
mehr außerdem essen wir auch einfach so
viel gemüse ich fand das was eigentlich
eine sehr sehr schöne entwicklung war
wie sich der garten nach und nach
vergrößert hat wir hatten immer viel
platz um uns zu tun neue sachen
auszuprobieren aber waren eigentlich nie
vom garten überfordert und das ist
natürlich auch total wichtig wenn man
anfängt zu gärtnern und so viel lust hat
dass man die sich nicht verdirbt in dem
man sich einfach zu viel vornimmt und
dann überhaupt nicht mehr hinterherkommt
es ist schon ganz gut wenn man
einigermaßen realistisch bleibt und sich
nicht überfordert aber gleichzeitig
finde ich es auch super wenn man sich
richtig viel zutraut weil ich zum
beispiel dachte das gärtnern viel viel
schwieriger wäre als es dann
letztendlich war also klar gibt es immer
wieder rückschläge
aber ich bin sehr froh dass ich nicht zu
zimperlich war am anfang und mir dann
schon relativ schnell relativ viel
zugetraut habe im garten weil das war
eine super entscheidung und es hat
bisher alles sehr sehr gut geklappt
es hängt natürlich alles komplett davon
ab wie es dir so mit deinem garten geht
für mich hast du ja gar nicht die
ambition so einen riesen garten zu haben
und die reicht ein kleines stück hinterm
haus schon völlig aus wenn du noch gar
keine erfahrung hast fang lieber klein
an vielleicht hast du ganz alleine ich
habe noch einen freund der mir hilft
beim gärtnern wenn sie einen großen
haushalt versorgen willst dann brauchst
du natürlich auch mehr fläche aber wenn
du vielleicht gar nicht so viel platz
was bei dir zu hause dann ist das schon
der begrenzende faktor also da spielt
ganz viel mit rein und deswegen weil das
sehr schwierig ist eine pauschale
antwort zu geben habe ich ein quiz
erstellt wo du diese fragen alle für
dich beantworten kannst und am ende gebe
ich dir eine einschätzung welche garten
größe für die ich die perfekte ist das
verlinkt ich dir gerne da oben also
macht das auf jeden fall mal ist eine
ganz lustige sache und dann fange ich
dir auch einen link unten in die video
beschreibung also wenn du eine konkrete
zahl haben möchtest welche bildfläche
ich dir für deine situation empfehlen
würde dann schau da auf jeden fall macht
und macht einmal mit ansonsten hängt es
natürlich auch sehr stark davon ab wie
man seinen garten bewirtschaftet wie
viel arbeit er macht und deswegen auch
gerne mal drüben vorbei da ist nämlich
ein video in dem ich der erzähle wie wir
unseren garten mit pflegeleicht
einrichten